anyone who is struggling not making
money in their business and they're
doing what they love and they're putting
the hard work and effort in what would
your one piece of advice be so on the
business side I would say you have to
learn how to figure out how to bring
value to people so doing what you love
is not enough but chasing strategy alone
isn't enough either so a successful
business comes from mixing what you love
doing with what brings value to other
people if you just love something but it
doesn't bring value you have a hobby and
that could be a great Hobby and
fulfilling but it's not going to become
a business and if you're just chasing
opportunity what's the hot business for
this year you're never going to
ultimately win long term because your
heart's not connected to it so and
you're going up against people who love
the thing and so it's in that
combination of the thing you love doing
that brings value to the people that you
have a successful business I know as
entrepreneurs we want more and more and
more it's like we want to start the
world we gotta change Global
Consciousness right I mean this is where
we want to go but but did you help one
person this week you know that did one
person benefit and so imagine if you
stopped you know if you stop often those
people won't get the message and if you
can continue to focus on who you are
serving because when you feel like
you're doing something that matters and
you feel like you matter you just show
up with a lot more love and energy and
care than otherwise and so if your
intent is to serve and to help just keep
going because the world needs people
like you need motivation watch your top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I want to
wake up every single day and get pushed
by somebody who's doing a lot more than
me and in watching their videos it
inspires me to be bolder to have more
courage and to go chase down the life of
my dreams and I hope it does the same
for you so today let's learn from me and
my team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy
rule number two is embrace your pain I
think a lot of people try to forget
about the past pain I think especially
entrepreneurs we're so you know
optimistic we want to make the world
better we're trying to live in a
positive Place uh that I have actually a
hard time remembering some of the super
painful moments and I don't like going
there but instead of trying to forget
and move past it if you can go live
there again just as a reminder of what
it felt like so that you can then help
other people living there and dwelling
on mistakes and and the hurt doesn't
help anything but if it allows you to
connect with the people who are
currently going through that situation
and I think that becomes your path like
for the reason why I came up with
purpose from your pain is it's one of
the most common questions I get is
what's my purpose how do I find my
people are walking around with no
purpose they don't know what it is and I
think everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something I think you can be a
genius at something and I know that like
Unleash Your greatness is what you're
all about it's great uh but people don't
know how to find and I think it starts
with that it starts with understanding
some of the pain and Trauma that you've
been through whatever that was for you
and then
then create something amazing you know
every great organization every great
entrepreneur who started out of a pain
that they had and then they wanted to go
off and solve it and so diving back into
your past to think about what were some
really painful moments and then how can
you turn that as a kick forward not a
kick down not that you know you suck but
you're gonna now help others and and
make it better
um and sharing the story I think is how
entrepreneurs win I think I think too
often we're afraid to share a lot of
people be afraid to share your story
like you're coming out of Tony Robbins
organization you're on top of the world
you're improving people's lives and and
you're sitting you know in your parents
basement and it's five years like that
that story is what makes people human
it's what connects people to each other
and I think
so many people were trying to start a
business uh try to be so corporate and
so professional and it's not that you
can't be professional but the thing
that's going to make somebody want to
work with you and connect with you and
your mission is your story I need to
know why this is so important to you why
is this pain so important and if you're
telling some
you know fluffy story it's not going to
work but if it's true and real to you
then that's what's really going to draw
people in rule number three is learn
from others I love learning different
things from different people I'm in my
home office and you can see pictures for
those listeners I guess there's pictures
behind me yeah man my parents are in the
middle let's I'm in the middle of me
when I'm like eight or nine wow
believe my one word my most important
core value comes from them uh they
taught me how to be a human
they didn't teach me about business
that's right
so okay great I've got Steve Jobs on the
wall here next to me he I like learning
how to be a Visionary like Steve Jobs
yes but I don't want to be a father like
Steve Jobs was that's right I want to be
a father like my father was that's right
and so I love learning different things
from different people I think anybody
who's had success you can learn from
them
and I honestly think some of your
greatest learnings will come from people
who you don't like my success yeah they
can teach you when you can learn to
learn from someone who you don't like
explain I think you actually start
learning
wow
and so my favorite comment of all time
on my channel I profile the uh a black
entrepreneur
and I had a guy leave a comment and say
hey growing up my parents told me that
black people were the n-word yeah
and today I just learned from a black
man yeah absolutely
that's it five minutes
like hey put your put your prejudices
aside for five minutes that's right and
rule number four is find your Niche if
you were looking at me and saying Andrea
your Niche you got to choose one or the
other or is there a way to emerge two
things into one in your opinion
so if you're looking at your audience
and picking your Niche what I what I
love to do is build around a core value
so
if you do if you're looking at health
and spirituality
those are not mutually exclusive
like you can't have help without
spirituality and you can't a spirit
trailer without help right I mean like
they go together and so the trick in
like what is your Niche is like what is
the Andrea brand
well it's about what's on what's on top
of that that makes it all make sense so
uh if you are only talking about
spirituality I had no connection to
health and only talk about health and no
connection spirituality then those could
live as two separate YouTube channels
and products and Brands but one it's a
lot more work
for someone like you to manage right
like now we got to manage two social
media accounts across everything and
it's also less of an expression of who
you are because you're always limited by
I can't talk about this stuff because
I'm only focused on X and so the
exercise that I like to go through with
people is like what sits on top so if
you have to think who does you know what
does Andrea stand for that's
spirituality is part of it and health is
part of it and maybe something else is
part of it too but what sits above like
what what's the mother word where
spirituality and health our children
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is turn your
passion into your business how do you
create a business from all this that you
have been doing and then it becomes
something quite quite quite quite
remarkable
yeah I think there's lots of ways to win
I think it's more what do you want to do
so I like helping people
so I like I like doing courses but not
just a course but I like I like training
I like I like having somebody in front
of me I like not just here's this course
I never have to see you again I like
seeing the person and coaching them and
guiding them even just before this I was
I was leading my community and it
actually used to be a course but then I
stopped it as a course and turned it
into a membership because
people are using the course but I never
got to see them I didn't get the I
didn't see the results of what they were
doing and now I get to meet people every
week and see what they're up to and how
I can help but that's that's not
necessarily the best way to do it it's
what do you love doing so you could sell
courses you can sell Consulting you can
sell your products you can sell your
services you can sell your books you can
sell your speaking you can sell your
hosting like there's so many things you
could sell
what is that you actually want to sell
that you love doing but I think it's
really important that when you are
getting started that you actually think
about how can you turn this into a
business how can you so that you're not
just wasting time like I could have
grown grown a lot faster in the early
days of my channel too if I thought
about it like a business and there were
less opportunities there are less ways
to do it compared to right now but a lot
of people just oh I just want to be
famous okay but how are we going to make
money doing the thing that you're
creating because if it's just a hobby
most people will probably quit if you
can't figure out a way to make money
most people will probably quit on the
thing and so it's like how do you you
have your purpose and your mission and I
love it yes and inside of that how can
we start to make money as soon as
possible so that you can stay dedicated
to it rule number six is be willing to
learn I've had people who
because I've made videos on Trump I made
videos on on Clinton the Clinton uh the
Trump one well the Trump one was one of
my favorites of yours as well
great I mean your people are very in
their in their biased camps but I like
that some people are crossing over just
just the willingness to learn I think
that's how you actually solve problems
absolutely the guy who grew up thinking
black people were the n-word now is
willing to learn like now we're changing
perspectives we're getting somewhere I
didn't set out to try to solve racism
but now it's a little tiny piece of of
the solution absolutely um
growing up with their parents and saying
like these people are the worst humans
alive and you can't learn anything from
them but Evan suggested that I watch his
video he's put up with
this guy to watch the video and now he
changes perspective
um I'm proud of that absolutely
who who will say never profile a black
person on your channel they got nothing
to teach you that's right I'll loot
those people okay but maybe I'll
absolutely absolutely and it's very
common that this is part of my ninja
whole strategy behind the channel that's
evolved my ninja strategies people come
in who to find people who look like them
it just is like like guys will gravitate
towards guys women towards women Tech
entrepreneurs who are attacked all of it
whoever's like you you want to go and
learn it's just natural yeah but I want
to I want to have those people bring you
in and then introduce other people who
don't look like you who don't come from
the same industry or the same background
and challenge you to try to learn from
that person I think that's where the
real learning comes and I think that's
where tolerance and understanding and
patience is built rule number seven is
build relationships what do you sell
like what's the main thing that you want
to sell
like um right now I have my books I
don't have many many other things maybe
I could come up with that many other
things but now I have my books and I I
am a speaker so but I haven't been
speaking quite much I I am in Europe
haven't been much further on out
cool so anything that you want to sell
should be a series on your channel so if
you want to sell books then the best
thing to do is
think about people who can recommend
your books and have them as a guest on
your show
so we're using the show for business
development so who can push a lot of
books and it might be entrepreneurs it
might be other influencers it might be
people from the book Community it might
be uh book agents anybody in the book
world people with a big list that they
might send it to people who run book
clubs right how do you have them as
guests on your show and we we almost
don't even care how well the video does
in terms of metrics on YouTube Facebook
whatever it's free to build the
relationship so that they get to know
you love you trust you and your book
becomes the next thing that they use in
their book club right if you made a list
of the top 500 book clubs in America
and then reached out to all of those
leaders who run the book clubs and have
them as guests on your show you're going
to get a lot more people reading your
book yeah okay it's being intentional
rule number eight is be of service to
others a lot of people tend to say put
others before you put yourself and for
me I've always thought that wasn't the
necessary correct way for me to operate
I know that when I put myself first when
I take care of my health and when I make
sure that I'm living in alignment with
my dreams I serve others better than
versus putting them first and then me
suffering and so for you has that been
something that's been natural to you I
think it's all
here
I mean an inspiration I think humans are
built to serve
period like I think if you're not happy
in life it's because you're not serving
somebody and some people are built to
serve the world like chances are the two
of us we're built to serve we want to
have a big impact we want our reach to
be wide we have a message that needs to
be heard yeah
but some people are just built to serve
the 25 closest people to them
perfect my wife is more like that's he
wants she's still in contact with her
friends from kindergarten but but
doesn't have a message that she wants us
to share with the world that's right
if you're not happy because you're
because you're serving others so it's
the same thing when you're happy you're
you're capable of serving more people
when you're growing
when you've taken another step on the
staircase you can pull more people up to
join you on that step um
but if you're staying at the ground
level you can't you can only help people
with things you've gone through and
grown through right
so the more you grow and learn the more
you can pull people up and help them and
that's ultimately what's gonna like I
said your purpose comes from your pain
the more you struggle and suffering then
grow the more you'll be able to help
other people go through that same thing
so I see them as the same thing
investing in yourself and learning
getting better and struggling allows you
then to help others but it's based off
of a default premise that people are
good like I believe humans are good
and that we're built to serve that's
amazing that if somebody's doing
something that's negative or wrong or
insulting or
imagine if you assume that so for
example in La my car was everything my
car was stolen I was on my own I was on
my tour
um they stole my gear my signs my wallet
my phone like they stole everything in
the car giant Suburban rated wow in a
private parking lot
um I think those people are good people
who are built to serve like whoever
stole from my car
they're good people who are built to
serve I just believe that rule number
nine is learn to balance your life how
do you balance your your home life your
work life what does balance look like to
you do you do you have a routine can you
tell us a little bit about it yeah I
think ultimately My Philosophy is your
actions have to map to your Ambitions so
what are your Ambitions what do you want
to create what's the what's your perfect
dream life I think part of being an
entrepreneur is we get to pick what we
do I mean that's why we become
entrepreneurs we want to create the
schedule that we want for ourselves so
what does a dream life look like for you
and it's not going to be all day working
you don't want to spend all day work on
your business
um you also don't want to spend all day
with your kids and you don't want to
spend all day with your spouse so what
is that balance and mix look like for
you and and that's a very personal
question I think part of where we
struggle is We compare Our Lives to
somebody else it's like oh well she's
such a super mom and she's doing all
these things and so I suck because I'm
not doing it like she's doing or like
he's doing it where this is a very
personal question and so
what I do is uh I have different dates
for different things so every morning
uh certainly with my morning routine
part of that includes if we're talking
family time part of that includes me
walking with my wife so this morning we
walked to Whole Foods we took the dogs
out it's starting to get warm here in
Toronto Canada which is amazing uh grab
the Americano from Whole Foods walk back
and just set up our morning what are you
working on today what you know how was
your sleep just connecting grounding
getting some sun in our face getting
some fresh air hanging with the dogs
like I like just that connection in the
morning to Nature and to my my pets and
my wife and you know it's a half hour
walk
um and then from there I'm mostly
working like today has been back to back
to back calls and podcasts and training
and just work work work work work uh I
have five minute gaps in between and my
wife works with me she's in the other
room I saw her outside on the balcony of
the dog so pop in say hi give her a kiss
come back like little micro moments like
that but for the most part it's just
work
um and then different days different
different actions today's we're filming
this on a Thursday that's my public
facing day where it's non stop
interviews and podcasts we'll do
something every night to hang out I'll
spend some time just with my wife
usually watching something relaxing with
the dogs on the couch kind of thing I'll
spend some time with my son often like
playing Minecraft or something fun that
he likes to do and then that's usually
Monday to Friday weekends are different
stories Saturday is fun day and so
Saturday we always do something for the
family that's not not work related and
not uh admin related so we're not going
grocery shopping we're not doing uh you
know condo cleaning or house cleaning or
whatever but something something fun
like there's a street festival or we're
gonna go for a hike outside we're gonna
try a new restaurant or just something
that we want to do and then Sunday is
family at midday where that's all of the
fold the laundry and clean up the office
and you know like whatever you have to
do to kind of run
everyone pretend the last time before
some very special bonus Clips is do what
you love what is your philosophy
uh in terms of is you studied all these
people what do you think for those
listening what are some of the core
elements of success that would be useful
to our listeners if you will
so I think the the number one rule that
comes up consistently and we've we've
covered people who are I started just
entrepreneurs and we've expanded to
athletes and musicians and innovators
and politicians and like anybody who's
had success from any Walk of Life the
number one thing that it all that they
all have in common is the love for the
work that they're doing yes loving the
the results but like loving the actual
work
often even when it doesn't make sense
for a lot of these people starting up
they have this passion for XYZ but
didn't make sense like there was no
business model attached to it I don't
know how it's going to work out and so
making the big decisions with the heart
and not the head you make the big
decisions with the hard and then use
your head to help figure out how you're
going to make it work is a consistent
theme across
um all the people that we profiled uh at
some at some degree you're gonna have
people who will will hate on your idea
will tell you that it won't work
especially the bigger the idea you have
the more people are going to hate
against it you know like a lot of people
say TJ we don't have greatness within us
come on man like what are you trying to
do and like and the bigger the mission
you have the more people fight because
it's changed they want to protect the
status quo and so if nobody's hating on
what you're doing then you're not you're
not actually living a great life
um in my opinion you don't have an
important enough Mission and so
expecting people to to hate on on your
ideas uh and then be able to deal with
it I think are some of the key things
that keep coming up over and over and
over and over again across all
successful people
how can people out there you know
discover for themselves when to actually
make that call to let go as someone who
wants to make things like happen and
make them a success how do you know when
to actually let go of something you let
go when you don't love it anymore
business a relationship if you don't
love it you should let go
as soon as possible
and most people found the Zoo camps one
they quit too soon they still love it
doesn't see a lot of entrepreneurs they
still love their business but it's not
working out and so they quit on it this
is why I went back to my business
because I still loved it if you quit on
it too soon and you still love it you're
going to regret that your whole life
yeah you're gonna ten years 20 years 40
years whatever you can look back and say
I could I could have done a little more
you know I could I quit too soon and so
if you still love it but it hasn't
worked out yet you have to keep going
otherwise you're going to regret it and
use that as fuel
the flip side is a lot of people who
stay in the thing for too long when
they're when they stop loving it people
stay in relationships too long when
they've stopped loving at the same
businesses for too long when they stop
loving it because they've had some
Success With It
you're not gonna see in a crappy
business forever if the business has
taken off but then you stop loving it
and you feel like you bought yourself a
job when you quit ASAP yeah like sell it
to somebody else and move on because
you're never going to win doing work
that you hate yeah that's why you still
have one foot in the pool of like it's
just okay I don't hate it I don't love
it can you tweak it so that you can love
it or is it time to want to go do
something else
um
this is what I do on the micro and the
macro always
I still love making YouTube videos I'm
I'm 6 000 videos in 10 years I still
love it but the day that I stopped
liking making videos if I have to go to
my camera be like I'm I don't I'm not
feeling it that's it all done
yeah done like I'll say hey you want to
take my YouTube channel you know try to
sell it move on or something else
because I'm never going to win doing
work that I hate yeah and that's a big
decision what you believe about yourself
is the only thing that matters at the
end of the day no matter how much
outside affirmations you get or other
people telling you that you're amazing
if you don't believe in your heart that
you are amazing none of that will last
like you've ever gone to an event or you
ever made a video or created something
or you're hanging out with a friend and
they tell you how amazing you are and
that feels good but then it fades but
that stuff doesn't last you don't have
somebody being a cheerleader for you
every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that you have to be
that for yourself if you're constantly
only getting your value as a human being
from other people when they tell you
that you're amazing you're never gonna
love your life you're never gonna love
yourself it has to come from you has to
come from you telling yourself and you
believe in that you are amazing like for
me this is why I believe that lack of
belief is the world's number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
feel them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe themselves
enough and so you have to design habits
and routines and systems and schedules
to slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward every single day how did you
grow your channel to millions of
subscribers so how I did it may not be
the best way for how you can do it right
now uh early on YouTube I started in
2009 it was a completely different game
than it is now where education was not
the main thing I made a six minute video
and people told me it was too long and I
was crazy and nobody would watch a six
minute video now YouTube is the number
one place people go to to learn the best
teachers are on YouTube you know they're
not in schools they're on YouTube so I
would start with you with well what's
the main thing that you watch you want
to sell I mean I'm looking to help Real
Estate Investors buy their first
property there's three main shows that
you can launch the first show is what
most people think about which is the
thought leadership show you're making
your eight ways to launch your real
estate career or whatever eight ways to
pick properties eight ways to blank
right that means you're a good speaker
it doesn't mean that you're actually a
good coach or know how to actually help
somebody show number two is you coach
people so you have either ideal clients
or people getting their start in the
business and you come on and you coach
them and that's a lot easier of a show
to make because you just have to show up
it assumes you're a good coach right
talking to a camera by yourself in the
studio is the hardest thing to do at the
beginning when you're actually helping
somebody it's a lot easier and then the
third show which is the fastest way to
make Revenue money is a Biz Dev show so
you think of who are the people who
generate leads for you like who are the
referral sources for you other investors
other lenders Bankers property managers
stuff like that so anybody who refers
business to you you start a show and
have those people and then those kinds
of people on your show talking to real
estate investing and those kinds of
people on your show talking about real
estate investing where the goal isn't
even to get a million views on the video
it's to build the relationships because
if a hundred different people inside of
the investing World knew who you were
who were all dealing with your ideal
clients now you've built the seven eight
figure business just off of those
relationships everybody has an off day
but it seems like you never do and I
think that and I'm sure you still do but
when you're on in front of the camera
you're doing it for the viewers you know
what I mean you're you're putting your
selfish you know bad day I guess aside
and you're focusing on the product and I
think that's awesome and that's really
attractive to me as a viewer that you're
willing to put in the commitment to spit
out three videos a day you know what I
mean yeah you know I uh I suffocate
negativity in my life it happens you
know
maybe my wife isn't happy in the morning
or maybe some of my team is is pissed
off when they started the day or
whatever right my natural reaction is
one to like try to avoid that situation
right for that time and then just I just
get so excited I don't know my default
is if there's negativity in my life I
need to suffocate it not give it any
oxygen and go the other way I don't know
where that comes from but it's not hard
to get up for it's not hard to get up
for this like I'm talking to dick I'm
pumped let's do it you know even if
something crappy happened just before it
doesn't matter I'm ready to go when I'm
making the videos for the channel it's
the same thing like it's easy to get
it's least it's easy for me to get all
excited about it because again it's tied
into the work that I do and and why I
you know the why of what I do try to
help entrepreneurs I believe
entrepreneurs are going to solve all the
major world problems not not operations
and not you know not Banks and not
governments it's entrepreneurs and so if
my work
uh adds a little bit half a percent to
make the difference for a dick or
whoever to go out and push a little bit
harder that's meaningful to me and so I
try to take that with me when I'm going
into filming day absolutely and just
suffocating that you're like you have to
you have to suffocate negativity out to
focus Heaven I think whatever you want
to sell show me the process of you doing
it so if you don't have an email list
yet you can even look at who's following
you on Instagram and message people and
say hey I I'm gonna do a free coaching
session for people who wants 25 minutes
of my time for free to talk about
coaching whatever issue you have you're
an entrepreneur whatever confidence
issue you're facing right now I will
Coach you for free but it's going to be
online okay those are two different
shows though the biz Dev show is we're
trying to build a relationship with a
potential client and get them on the
show to tell their story but then inject
a little bit of what you do 25 of the
show is about you and confidence
coaching helping them the second show is
just a straight up coaching show where
they know they're coming on
but they may not be they may not be an
ideal client for you which is anybody
who needs okay okay
because I need I want to see that you're
a good coach because you can talk and
you can give me your Frameworks XYZ and
you can you can have all of your
material you can but that makes a good
speaker
how do I know if you're a good coach
right like Ted Williams was a great
baseball player but he wasn't a great
coach so you could be a great speaker it
doesn't mean you're a good coach so how
do I know if you're a good coach I need
to see you coach
so you that's a that's a separate series
on the channel so now we're splitting it
up between the biz Dev show where we're
trying to get clients and a coaching
show where we're we don't care if
they're ideal clients are not coming on
We're just trying to show coaching and
and help them of course and help them
and then if you have your website or you
build out your funnel that then becomes
content so when somebody lands on your
hey hire Frankie to be your coach I can
see examples of what you do and how you
coach people don't try to monetize your
compassion it's a joke you might suck at
your passion monetize what you're great
at Naturally you need to mix what you
love with what there's a domain for okay
if you love it but there's no demand you
have a hobby and that can fill your soul
but it's a hobby if you're just chasing
what's hot but you have no interest in
it you're never gonna win because you're
going up against people who absolutely
love the thing it's in that intersection
of what you love doing with what there's
a market for what about all the things
that are really difficult to love guy
sells toilet bowls for a living people
sell sports it's Hardware steel how do
you love steel or is that's not the
actual business itself is it passionate
about manufacturing or passion about
building an organization it's got to be
a passion for the process if you're
we're doing this on a Monday right if
you're waking up on a Monday like oh
you're done you got to be excited about
the work that you're about to go off and
do and from all the people that I've
studied that's that's the number one
trade love of the process of what
they're doing every day you are making
80 videos in one day you know so yeah uh
basically all the videos for a month and
one day
um dude one do you still do that and two
um what's the logic behind that and
where do you find the time management
for something like that because that's
one of my uh one of my big downfalls I'm
not so good with time management that's
something I'm learning myself
yeah so
I don't do 80 a day anymore that's when
I was filming once a month I film once a
week now and so we'll cut that back to
20 ish videos a week
um more because I'm spending more time
on each of the videos and my team is
preparing things for me that that were
not a month ahead on uh for the time
management it's just
your your actions eat the map to your
ambitions
and so you have Ambitions and not just
business Ambitions life Ambitions like I
don't know if you're married or not or
kids or not or but whatever your life
Ambitions are
then I I default to looking at my
calendar
and I say okay I look at my week next
week if I did the things that are in my
calendar for next week am I moving
closer to hitting my ambitions or not
so if I'm if I'm making videos then yeah
but if I spend a week and there's no
videos happening then no I'm not I'm not
getting closer to my missions
and so if you think that your time
management is an issue now you know it
only gets harder as you grow bigger like
if you I have 24 people on my team it's
harder you know like I gotta manage all
these people on top of managing myself
uh and so one I remind myself of
whatever I'm doing right now whatever
challenge I think that's in front of me
I tell myself this is just a warm-up
like this is just a warm-up I'm capable
of more I'm capable of more than what
I'm facing right now because we feel
like the current problem is overwhelming
then that's the limit of what you're
capable of doing so this is just a
warm-up
then I look at uh I look at my calendar
and I look at my goals and I see how do
I how do I match these things up
uh I'm a I'm a huge believer and this
may not work for you but I chunk my days
so Thursday is my public facing day you
know I we're talking on the Thursday I
don't know when you guys are going to
launch this thing but I'm an introvert
and so that may not come across you may
not believe me but I am and and I need
to get up for for public I call this
public facing day so I need to get up
for my interviews and it's been all day
interviews and podcasts and hangouts and
and meetups and that's my Thursday every
day
and I like that because I have a really
hard time switching tasks like to talk
to you guys and be all fired up and
energetic and then go and write my book
and then come back and then do another
interview like I I can't the energy
level it's doable but it just sucks so
much for me that it's better for me to
say in one zone for the day I find that
super helpful most entrepreneurs aren't
patient enough most entrepreneurs end up
losing their business they end up
shutting down because they think it's
gonna happen in a couple months or even
six months or a year and really it's
gonna take them four years five years
before they hit their Mark they don't
have enough patience they don't allow
enough time for momentum to build up and
they quit and they end up going back to
a crappy job that they hate and maybe
never ever take a shot and get an
entrepreneurship because they feel it's
not for them well really they missed out
you missed out on your destiny you
missed someone creating something
amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now I believe in patients in
the macro I believe in patience and
knowing it's going to take a long time I
also think inpatients can serve you
greatly but that's in the micro that's
in the daily the impatience of did I do
my best today did I do my best today can
I do better can I drive more can I drive
harder and knowing that even if I give
my best every single day it's still
going to take time
it's still going to take a number of
years for something to happen I want it
to happen as soon as possible I'm going
to drive and be impatient as crazy to
get it going but I know it's going to
take time too it's embracing both that's
when you start to win I look at my my
YouTube my Instagram my social media
strategy YouTube 7
000 subscribers four years ago 1.2
million subscribers now four years by
making videos every day every day and
I'm impatient as anything because I want
it to be amazing I want to make every
video better than the last and looking
for all the hacks and SEO on thumbnail
strategies and title strategies and all
of the stuff that we're supposed to do
right I'm on top of it and I know that
it's going to take me four years to get
there I know it's going to take me a
while to get to my next 2 million five
million 10 million I look at Instagram
follow me on my Instagram Journey I'm
starting from nothing you can see how to
build it up from zero I had eight
thousand followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm going to make daily consistent
content three to four times a day for
four years I'm gonna be impatient as
anything and that the post today has to
be amazing has to be something that I
want to show my grandkids right that's
the intent every time I create anything
I want my grandkids to watch this video
I want grandkids to watch the next
Instagram thing that I put up it's the
best that I can come up with in the
moment and I know it's going to take me
four years maybe three years maybe two
years but it's not gonna take me two
months
I realize it's gonna take working hard
and working smart together always what
your current morning routine looks like
so I go through five s's uh sing Sun
sore sweat scare so sing I put on music
right away and any song that will get
you like if it came on you'd have to
bounce and you'd have to sing right yeah
um
so right now there's a there's a Chinese
wrap that I did it's a Chinese song that
I did a rap in English on top of yeah
and so I play that every morning
um Chinese rap is like dance or is it
really straight up like hardcore rap uh
I'm rapping yeah to a Chinese song so
there's this woman who's rapping and I
sped her up and then I'm rapping over
the Parts where she's not singing that
was a fun little project that I worked
on so I like it makes me move so I I'm
rapping to my own song every morning
while it comes on but whatever song gets
you up and ready to go because we wake
up and you know you're tired and
starting your day and so music is the
fastest way to change your state like as
soon as it comes on in five seconds you
can already be feeling better right oh
yeah and there's no one Magical song
it's whatever it is for you and
the audience then Sun so I like to get
outside so we've got two dogs they're in
here with us today I like to get outside
outside just to get some fresh air on my
face we're in Toronto's December there's
not a lot of sun happening right now but
just just getting out of your
environment even if you work from home
the walk from just your bedroom to the
office you can carry with that still the
tired energy of the bedroom right so get
outside get some fresh air even if it's
just go out on the balcony and just take
in some sun for a little bit mother
nature mother nature makes a difference
then soar so this is the most important
part what is the thing that you need to
do every day that makes you feel bold
powerful Unstoppable confident alive
whatever that thing is do it first thing
in the morning
instead of waiting like maybe it's
listening to the paper Paradise podcast
or watching the video series now it's
happening if that's a thing then then
you watch it every morning you listen to
it every morning
um
most of us don't have enough intention
behind the day yeah and so I know it's
part of what you do in the morning too
but for me it's I go live on Instagram
so service if I feel like the work that
I'm doing matters is important I'm
serving somebody it makes me more amped
up for the day so so I'll go live on
Instagram every morning and people join
in from around the world asking
questions and I help them in a quick
half hour
um and that's what I need to do so other
people maybe it's meditation maybe it's
prayer maybe it's
something like anything whatever the
thing is that makes you feel bold
powerful confident if you started your
day with the thing that made you feel
bold and Powerful your your year is
going to look totally different like
where you are in one year will be
totally different than where you are
right now amen
um and then the last two are just sweat
and scare so I'll do a workout and then
hop into a cold shower because like what
do you like to do for working out
um usually I'll do a 100 push-ups 100
squats what am I doing now 100 push-ups
hundred squats and 100 jumping jacks
yeah and then you do like the Wim Hof
the whole like cold hot that's it uh not
hot just cold just cool just cold yeah
there's no hot in the Wim Hof no no I
mean like the cold like the whole the
the Heat and coolness like you get
really worked out like sweaty oh yeah
you do the cool then jump into the cold
yeah and you're just getting started in
all of this right yes the opportunity
here is
there's the big long-term opportunity of
you could help whether it's everybody
whether it's women whether the female of
color or whatever that says a lot of
people in
even just North America who need that
yeah
the immediate opportunity is figuring
out okay how do we how do we replace our
salary correct because the the women on
the train may not be able to afford you
as a coach right so this is where a lot
of people get stuck right at the
beginning I love these people and
they're so good like you didn't want to
help and then you get you get pulled
into either helping them for free or
doing it like super discounted rate yeah
and you feel so fulfilling but it's like
you are not making money right so it's
it's just an order of sequencing so it's
not
that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money
so that we can afford to quit our job
and then make more money so we can
afford to hire team to help us build our
brain so like on purpose first yes you
have to learn how to monetize right
right number one is Mission purpose and
then somewhere in two to five has to be
making money if you're an entrepreneur
or you don't make money is there a habit
that you formed that helped you that
helps you break through that
introversion and make those videos every
single day
uh so yeah so one
default into service so I remember I was
I was uh late last year I was speaking
in front of a couple thousand people in
Phoenix and I I blanked out 10 minutes
before going on stage I blanked out I
forgot what I was gonna say and in my
head like oh my God Brandon burchard and
Ian graciosi invited me to come and
speak at their event and I'm speaking
after Eric Thomas and and I'm I'm
blanking I just imagine myself getting
on stage and having a meltdown and just
letting everybody down and what I did
was I I peeked from backstage to the
audience and reminded myself it's not
even about me it's about them like I'm
here for them stop being so selfish get
out of your way you've gone knowledge I
can help them and go out there and serve
and so the serving gives me the strength
to overcome the the anxiety and stress
plus I built an identity around if I say
scary difficult or hard that means I
have to do it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Gary vaynerchuk
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there you're gonna
learn something real powerful that I'd
like to talk about right now when you
are 90 you rarely talk about what you
did you always talk about what you
didn't do if you were lucky enough and
if you wanted to get inspired to spend
just a little time six hours